I believe it it's called much apush yes
and it's uh it's quite common isn't it
yes at this call it been common and
still it's common and I've harnessed on
because actually why why it's happening
why this practice happen in our society
because our society's very a religious
society and they are very conservative
people so the thoughts come from there
that in the village and the remote area
on grass root area the thing that ok
when you have certain girl at the home
so just and then the way to supplicate
to the god they are changing the
youngest girl to boy or decision to boy
so just to show their PT or they're
feeling for the god and supplicate to
God to give them a son next time so this
this practice come from there then when
the internal war started on Afghanistan
and we have certain conflict and still
we have the conflict so formally to keep
their life more secret and secure they
start to change the girders to the boy
and later on some families because of
the word they lost their breadwinner and
they had number of girl at the home so
what should they do so the easy way was
to just earn some money and also to earn
something from outside for the life
experience of the family so they start
this paratus what about yourself how
were you brought up you brought up but
suppose as well uh actually yes I've
been part of part time betcha push
actually when the when you when you were
young I was even in the letter H when I
become 12 actually I start to become
batcha push and so my father had a big
store so I've been with my father as a
his son so I've been in the shop for 23
years but after that because my growth
was so fast I become so tall suddenly so
that's why I quit and then I came back
and I'm remember I really enjoyed that
time and I really learned a lot because
even that time was more freedom and of
course at was Russian time we had more
freedom special and Kabul but you know
it's led me to learn a lot and I got
lots of experience it with the man how
to just learn from their attitude and
later on when I engaged
politics and I start my campaign for in
2005 for the Parliament as a member of
the Parliament so I when I start my
company was quite easy for me to
communicate with the man grabbed their
attention get their wood and be more
energetic and like a with lots of men
attitudes and you learn how to how to
behave like you're like a man yes yes it
was quite easy for me because in
Afghanistan is still men well they are
deciding that ok you should for the
woman that you should look for whom so
you have to convince the men to get the
word of woman also this is I mean this
is a country words it's very hard to be
a woman um I'm part of the reason that
that NATO has been there for more than
10 years is to change these politics uh
do you think they have succeeded or
obviously not you sexy do you have a
success okay so first of all I would say
that I'm very impressed by you because
you are so brave and you're standing up
for the rights of women in Afghanistan
and I think you also illustrate how much
difference individuals can make when it
comes to changing in society
conservative society like Afghanistan
when it comes to weather NATO has
succeeded or not I think we have to
remind ourselves for the fact that we
went into Afghanistan and the main
reason for doing that was to prevent
that Afghanistan is a safe haven for
terrorists organizations and we have
achieved that but in addition we are
worked with the Afghans to try to create
a society where the Africans can decide
their own future and we have very much
underlined the importance of good
governance and when I listen to you I
understand there is a long long way yet
to go and i hope that can support you
and your greater for to move afghanistan
forward on to make it a better country
for women in Afghanistan thank you so
much but why what I on want to act in
that yes we are grateful from NATO from
our international community to came to
Afghanistan also help us to survive of
that very difficult time but in terms of
women right if you say specifically we
are coming to this point yes
we had achievement we had a chief man
till two thousand five or six but after
that the graph goes down again because I
just I just shared with you some
information from last month and it's
very shocking for me hollister for me as
a mom of four daughters it's very
shocking for me because in last man we
had 42 cases of child draping and
different part of Afghanistan there's
register cases of 50 child marriage
between the nine to thirteen years old
you can't imagine how or death is and
also this and also that the violence
against women's Society violence
domestic violence political virus every
day raised up every day they serve in my
country but this is only the register
case those people which got access to
the media or access to the Human Rights
Committee and register themselves and
them their cases but there's thousand
cases especially in the south of
Afghanistan but nobody knows what's
happening there you know and south of
Afghanistan there sell their wife
they're just taken like a material in
the bazaar and then somebody come and
choose their wife and they're selling
them and I'm sharing with you another
secret which is unbelievable with you
because I know that most of the time
when people talk about Afghanistan and
woman right the first thing is bokra Oh
Afghan woman wearing bokra and it is not
it is not it's not like a difficult I
word bakra for more than five or six
years my first company i did with burka
and there's our if my well that has
really been in the West that is a symbol
of oppression yes this this is not a
symbol of project I'm ready to wear to
Borca but who give me immunity who give
my safety who will secure my country
that is the question and I'm here to
raise this wise and whys of thousand
people thousand o silent woman that
they're born in silent and dying silent
and they never know and they never know
that they're human and they have some
basic right and they should have access
to that aisle seat all thank you for
giving them a voice
please welcome from Kabul a sitter
you